ils lui ont tout pris
pokémon
son fusil
sa dignité sa carte d'identité pour un
petit contrôle mais aujourd'hui il
revient plus fort que jamais prêt à me
battre
tu vois clairement aujourd'hui on va pas
prendre le même chemin aujourd'hui on va
prendre le plus grand des tours possible
on va passer par la picardie sévère ici
au niveau de cette fenêtre sur le fil
mais voilà tu es vraiment conséquent la
picardie que j'avais accès de phonak
aujourd'hui on est de retour plus fort
que jamais je peux dire qu'on va
capturer un max de pokémon mon pote
l'espace et le réflexe donc là comme tu
peux le voir sur la carte aux alentours
il ya ce qu'on appelle un salamèche qui
est bien avec pokémon gosses et
personnages mais compris système des
pokémon proches
c'est chaud se trouve alors ça la magie
vers où tu es toi jacques c'est la
petite boussole ça l'argent pas si tu es
moi vous aurez pas vu un salamèche la
pâte à la mèche
vous l'avez capture est pour ça que vous
foutez de ma gueule ou la capture avant
moi [ __ ] ils en sont sacrifiés dans
son cinq ans car ce n'est pas cette
rivalité la da bahia un car l'herbe rien
qu'à aller on va se poser dans l gossio
qui arrivèrent bon paquet sur mon
cinquième pas question avons-nous court
court que portent ces mots salamèche ça
bouge ça bouge et un pokémon
ce tarif c'est arielle à l'écarter
écarté mais les quintés m'y installe
pour votre bien il est sur le mot [ __ ]
on allait s'asseoir dessus mais qu on
l'a il s'échappe et [ __ ] à cause
d'elles est loin [ __ ] lui ont fait
peur mais ça c'est chiant ça ils veulent
me mettre des bâtons dans les roues tu
comprends ce que je te dis moi je veux
ce salamèche est ce ce tarif mais
surtout salamèche vidéo sur youtube sur
pokémon gobain là j'attends je cherche
un but bizarre il y en a un qui est pas
loin je ne trouve pas vous avez une
petite indication que d'être mené ma
fille m'a parlé de ça il ya deux jours
ça dans quelle équipe allait jaune rouge
blanc c'est monsieur vous savez je me
suis allé rouge revenant ici revêt la
csk les rouges c'est la short list et
barrières commencent à souffler mans
écoute je vais donner nos recettes de
grand mère que mon grand père m'avait
donné du coup ce dont ses deux
grands-pères et salamèche sont très
friands des pistaches
surtout quand tu as ouvert le paquet à
l'envers et audio ça at il un [ __ ] de
l'audio c'est pas ça la met sous les
voies la technique des pistaches tu as
retenu un domaine technique de dressage
quand vous voyez un pokerstop avec un
leurre ça veut dire que des gens autour
qui essaient de capturer les pokémon
fait nous on va voler leurs pokémon
ok on est arrivé mais non le lard a
disparu le leur a disparu respect sur la
route connaît c'est pourquoi le leur a
disparu presque on n'a pas été assez
rapide pour qu'on n'a pas été assez
rapides et j'arrive plus à part le fait
même eu la pudeur je suis ému moi je
pensais rencontrer des pressions des
dresseurs tous qui dresse des gâteaux
c'est maintenant l'heure de la troisième
astuces procurez-vous un véhicule rapide
mais pas trop
[Musique]
je serai maire
pour avoir les grands pokémon il faut
employer les grands moyens
[Musique]
gamez
mais
[Musique]
je pars touré
ça
[Musique]
mais la bulle bizarre il ya un but
bizarre ryumbeke 13 ans a pu la merde
comme ça on n'en veut pas on va pas le
jeter on va le donner on va faire un don
j'ai des fans avec grand plaisir les
gars sont tous blessés parce que j'ai
plus grands pokémon de la terre c'est ça
ça c'est entendu ça j'ai entendu alors
est ce que vous savez s'il ya un
salamèche ou un truc bien pas loin si tu
veux du produit taillé en tenue d'adam
quoi les pénitents clément ni mort ni un
défaut ni mon gars tu l'as ac ac est
allé bon état swag
tu t'appelles pop sommes dans le jeu ne
sais pas comment tu vas me faire un
cadeau je vois qu'à se plaît on a trouvé
le parc ça sans peau ni ta mon pote hop
hop hop hop vous êtes des dresseurs team
blot à jouer à pokémon go team blot au
canada tim le r6 team le bal alors merci
au pardon merci merci
allez les gars bonne chasse à et
n'oubliez pas vivre la team bleus ont
dégagé mytho mais c'est aussi ça pokémon
gausser de l'infiltration juno relative
rouge
bonjour messieurs comment allez-vous sa
capture du pokémon dépit des tacles là
dessus parce que ça s'est montée à terre
c'est ma zone qu'est ce que tu attends
entrevoir tu attends je vais regarder
plutôt là bas au laser capable
c'est ça qu'on fait c'est ça c'est ça il
ya des dresseurs là bas on va aller les
voir
c'est la réputation vous avez capturer
quoi comme pokémon impôts ni ta capture
égale un pénible pour squeeze tu sais
pourquoi je touchais un pokémon sur
chaque pokémon capturés sinon jean bart
ont fait que je me casse les ruptures et
les renforts reconnaît on à sécuritaire
faut y aller faut y aller faut y aller
faut y aller faut y aller on est entouré
faut y aller tu vas planète
je souhaite passer la main merde on voit
bien la bonne appli web l'a tellement on
trouvera son oncle et de bonita n'est
pas les parisiens servir bien clément
clément clément il parle il est la clé
657 je fume pas marrer dukurs vraiment
c'est ce qui s'est passé
on est petit à l'heure où puis c'est par
une baisse des fonds aujourd'hui on a
appris plein de choses c'était intense
c'était génial
c'était le meilleur dresseur en action
attrapez les tous
[Musique]
ça
gros couac moines il faut employer les
grands moyens